if you want really want to understand
what's on a written page right now we
need a human to read it that's very slow
we will get I believe technology very
soon that can actually do a pretty good
job of reading natural language
documents Watson shows that that's
feasible if you consider Watson was
actually able to read Wikipedia and
understand it well enough to play a game
of this Jeopardy which is a complex
subtle ambiguous game of language and
got a higher score than the best human
players put together and its knowledge
was not programmed it's fact by fact in
Lisp or some computer language it it
just read Wikipedia and other
encyclopedias 200 million pages of
natural language documents and didn't do
a perfect job of understanding it and
didn't do a perfect job of answering the
questions but it was better than the
best to humans put together from having
read
natural language documents it's very
impressive that's coming to a search
engine near you is made you know major
search engines like Google are not just
going to be using keywords with synonyms
they're going to actually read for
understanding the concepts because if
you think about searching there's a lot
a lot of information now that's ignored
which is the meaning of all these
documents which is why they were created
so if you can have a computer and even
do a job that's may be mediocre compared
to you and but but they can apply the
scale of computation so I mean Watson if
it read one page it's not as good as you
are but it didn't read one page it read
200 million pages you and I can't begin
to do that Watson's are reading all
medical literature or every medical
journal article every medical book major
medical blogs and will be an expert
diagnostician and medical consultant
that has read everything no human can do
that so that's where we're headed our
search engines will actually also know
us very well we will let them listen in
our conversations verbal
they'll watch everything we're reading
and writing and saying and hearing and
then they'll be like a assistant it'll
say you know you were talking about how
you can get this supplement
phosphatidylcholine into the cells
yesterday in that conversation with joe
you know there was research that came
out thirteen minutes ago that speaks to
that it will be an assistant that helps
you through the day the day will answer
your questions before you ask them or
even before you realize you have a
question and you'll just get used to
this information pumping up that you
want it and you'll be a minute you'll be
frustrated if you're thinking about
something and it doesn't immediately pop
up without you even having to ask for it
now I'm not actually predicting that
until 2029 that we will match human
intelligence but we can nonetheless do
things that humans can't do I mean
Watson if it read one page as I said
wouldn't be as strong as your eye but it
was able to read hundreds of millions of
pages and its ability to read each page
is going to increase so that's where
we're headed but then a comment on that
is it's not an alien invasion of these
intelligent machines to displace us we
will use them to make ourselves smarter
which is what we do today